he's the manager for the Miami Marlins
Don Mattingly
how are you Donnie doing good dan missed
you guys listen I got down on your list
it sounds like well now we were waiting
if something controversial happened if
you got in trouble you gotta ejected and
then I saw where you said you're in
favor of the automated strike zone the
Robo umpires that surprised me a little
bit how did you come to that realization
I just I just think watching these games
and the technology has gotten so good
with that and really gained the game as
you watch so many so many calls for me
and I know there's a gray area they call
and things like that I just think it
would make it a cleaner game it keeps me
from getting ejected working in balls
and strikes but I really I really do
think it's it's getting to that point
why do we allow umpires to have their
own interpretation of the strike so I
find that now I maybe we do that in all
other sports where you know of football
referee has his own interpretation of
holding or basketball referee has his
interpretation of traveling but when the
strike zone varies that much I I don't
understand why we gave them so much
power I don't I don't necessarily think
that we've given so much power I think
they you know there's a definition of
you know what the strike zone is you
know some guys just see it differently
and you know I think the new setups I'm
pretty sure that they don't allow the
guys that set up right behind the
catcher anymore they want them in the
slot which puts them in a bind guys are
throwing harder and harder those move so
much movement and it's just it's just
getting tough to to keep that thing
regulated I think the auto zone or the
Robo lumps whatever you want to call it
get regular it will regulate the strike
zone it will reward the guys that know
the strike zone as hitters and it will
yes guys are still going to chase but if
it will reward those guys for knowing
the strike zone and an actual reward
the guys that can do it on the mound too
so it doesn't reward the guy that's
filling the ball 98 but it's not hitting
corners he's just missing but it's close
and and he's getting called you put the
hitter in a tough spot Kershaw was on
with us recently he said he's not
interested in it he's not for it I would
think that it would it would help him
even more he said look I don't want to
there are there are jobs you know with
catchers who are really good at framing
a pitch and I said that's not enough to
not do the automated strike zone I would
think that would help someone like
Kershaw what do you think well I've done
respect for Clayton obviously he's a
great guy and a great pitcher for a long
time but you know I do disagree I just
think that we can regulate this thing I
think the technology is good enough to
be able to to get it where that
curveball that barely crosses and
bounces on the ground they can they can
they can regulate that enough we're well
guys we'll know what a strike is and
what a ball is and not from one day to
the next when you get one guy that till
we get scouting reports every day on the
UMP and we see this box that they call
more often and the spots they miss more
the top of the strike zone is a place
where guys are going now some guys call
the top some guys don't and it just gets
it's hard for me as I watch you know um
part of umpire each zones a little bit
different and not that they're trying to
be different it's just that they are
they may not see the right side of the
plate and may be missing you know you
know one side of the plate more often
get the other side there's a little bit
of space out there so I think it just
regulates it where strikes the striker
balls a ball how much did you benefit
from having a great eye that the umpire
might have consciously or subconsciously
leaned towards helping you at the plate
I think it's I think it helps guys I
feel like I did benefits um I wasn't a
guy that that struck out a lot but I
didn't actually walk very much either
but I felt like I knew the strike from a
ball and I I you know you learn how to
talk with guys for me you know if a ball
you know if the ball was closer but it's
an inch and a half off I'm gonna say hey
I know that's close but that's an inch
and a half off you know that you know I
mean so I want to let him know that I
know this strike zone I want him to pay
attention and so I think you you get
respect in that order if you know how to
talk to them and then also you're not
swinging at everything that comes up
there you know guys that swing it balls
over their head and then on the ground
I'm gonna argue a ball it's an inch off
you know there's another part you're
like okay you're swinging at everything
up here you don't know a ball from a
strike so you can't really talk to me
like that he's Don Mattingly manager the
Miami Marlins Continental Tire Coach's
Corner home runs are way up this year
because of what you know I don't know
they keep going up and every year it
seems like and you know this year the
ball seems to be flying but you hear
that same thing almost every year the
last few years all the balls are juiced
this or that but I will say we've been
to some ballparks
that in the past I've you know you watch
BP and you watch games and balls are hit
and they're going places that you don't
see them you didn't see him go in the
past and all the players getting bigger
and stronger or guys throwing harder so
if you catch it it goes further I don't
know but in general I'm you know guys
are going to get bigger and stronger as
this game keeps evolving but it's
something is a little different this
year can you have too much of a good
thing though can you can we have too
many home runs no not necessarily I
don't think I think the biggest
complaint with the home runs you know
with in baseball is that it's all or
nothing right now
you know it's home run its walk its
strikeout are you touching that are you
teaching your kids that
no we you know we don't mind homeruns we
also want we also want guys that can put
the ball in play you know it's tough
when you get a guy on third you can't
get him in because you get two straight
strikeouts and you know or pop up to the
infield and you can't hardly get that
guy in and you can't really do anything
it's hard to hit and run it's hard to
put the game in motion when you got guys
that can't put the ball in play and so I
think there's got to be a balance of
guys that can put the ball in play
aren't striking out quite as much so
there's more action in the game and I
think that's kind of the biggest
complaint within the game now is that
there's not enough action in beer here's
somebody that watches football or
basketball or other sports it seems like
there's action all the time
yes and in baseball if you watch a
baseball game it's like you know it's
just the tempo of it which is the beauty
of the game it you know it's kind of
almost a Hinda scheme if it's played
perfectly but I think for the younger
generation the game is a slow game and
you know they don't seem to like it as
much yeah even a sacrifice bunt or
hitting the ball to the other side you
know opposite side of the infield that
that just doesn't happen and I think we
took movement for granted Donnie back
when we were growing up or even when you
were playing that there were things that
were going on now it's that guy throws
98 and that guy sitting dead red and may
the best man win and maybe you'll get a
base hit or something but that's about
it I know it's tough you know it's funny
even as a manager and we shift as much
as anyone
there are times and we're playing that
guy work he's got a hit if he wants it
if he could run it I base it it's just
like and they don't and and for the most
part guys don't
and then amazing that's amazing it is to
me because you know you're three or four
runs down your run means nothing other
than we need base runners and we're
playing a guy all the way over and they
don't take the opportunity I mean it's
hard for me to even do it it's like
man why does that guy not take it but
they don't what's your favorite George
Steinbrenner's story I guess the one I
always think about is a conversation I
had with him when him and I were I guess
going back and forth you know over a
situation and he was talking about
trading me Dallas Green had taken over
the club in 89 and he asked me says hey
do you want to be here I said yeah I
want to be here but I want to be treated
with respect and do you mind giving
George a call I said I'm sure so I call
him and we start getting into it a
little bit and back and forth over the
respect and you know I you know I tell
him I say hey I come to camp in shape I
play hard every day I'll play hurt for
you but you got through through SPECT
and and he says well he get he goes you
know he kind of talks and he says well
good luck to you and he hangs up on me
[Laughter]
18th season and so I'm kind of getting
ready I'm going back to Indiana and kind
of packing up the house and I told my
wife at the time I'm like Moz will put
this thing on the market we're gone and
from that point on he treated me with
respect and we had a great relationship
and from that point on it was it was
great it was almost like okay you stood
up for yourself now you know now we can
move forward
where were you going to get traded to
I've heard you know you never know but I
heard some real Clark stuff to San
Francisco I don't know what was going on
with him or whatever but that's what I
heard nice well we'll stay with that it
sounds kind of that that's an
interesting trade rumor there before I
let you go I want to ask you about that
bench-clearing brawl with the Pirates in
the Reds as as a manager what do you
what how do you preempt that what is
your role if you know that this is going
to happen or somebody's hit and then
there's retaliation somebody Cadillacs a
home run what is your role
well I think I you know as a manager
really you have to try to keep the game
in order you don't want your guys
getting thrown out of games you don't
want guys getting suspended you have to
be a leader in those situations I
haven't always been that honestly I mean
I've gotten fired up and you get it you
get involved and you get emotional but I
think in general you got to try to keep
your club under control we don't want
you don't want guys getting hurt and and
there's a lot of craziness in the game
with all the kind of let the kids play
thing has caused some issue you know you
see the you know not just hit the home
or and kind of admiring it a little bit
it's it kind of gets to the point
sometimes you're like man somebody's got
to go somebody's going to get hit for
that one day right and it and right now
it's it's the players I think in general
with that mindset and pretty soon I
think we're moving towards where
pitchers start dancing after every
strikeout and talking to guys like get
back in the dugout you know go take a
seat and as that keeps going I feel like
it's gonna get worse and worse so
hopefully you know the players
themselves can get a handle on this we
want him to me it goes back to respect
you know you had a home run hey you feel
good but you know you still want to
respect the game itself and do we want
literally kids pimping homers tossing
bats is that what we want to see out of
a nine-year-old you know coming up in
this game so I think we have some sort
of responsibility to teach some
sportsmanship and respect towards each
other and I think we still gotta have
fun there is a play obviously one guys
to have fun had a good time but I think
there's at some point there needs to be
some sort of line that ordinary guys
with respect of the 222 home runs I
think that's your total that you had did
you ever really watch one did you did
you admire one a little too long I don't
think so I think the one time that I may
have pimped one a little bit it was in
Chicago Chicago Comiskey and I remember
not feeling good that day I was
was kind of beat-up kind of feel like I
had a little cold coming on and the
first time up they threw like three
balls behind me and I didn't even think
about it really the little days you were
like okay he's trying to pitch me in
whatever this is I sit there between me
I'm like he tried to hit me every time
and I got somebody and I got the lefty
the next time I'll be humming me a
curveball hit him out and I probably
took a little little longer get around
the bases on that one why were they
throwing at you now you never know like
you know in the past honestly guys would
throw at you and it was really a sense
of respect they want to find out hey
this guy's doing damage I'm gonna fire
some balls in there and see if he still
wants to cover that outside part of the
plate well so there was some respect
there when guys you know want to knock
you down but you know I'm not quite sure
the reason it was uh it was Tony was
LaRussa with the White Sox in and I
don't feel like I did anything other
than maybe maybe we hit somebody in
there and it it was kind of a payback
I'm not sure was it Floyd Bannister no
it was uh I think it was Lana guusto is
the guy I hit the homer off of and he
gave me all kinds of trouble but it
seemed he hung me one on that one hey
did you ever challenge did you go to the
mound I don't think everyone to the man
is traded I remember getting hit in
Oakland another Tony maybes LaRussa
didn't like you I love Hillary I think
he's great we hit we hit Mac I think
Dave Lapointe hit him and he got hit and
hit him in the head and he'd been hit a
couple of times that year and but it was
a 3-1 pitch he's trying to get in and
Oakland had all those monsters at the
time and they kind of stood on the plate
and just dared you if he didn't pitch
him in they were going to kill you yeah
and so we attack and it's it's like I'm
the third hitter two outs nobody on and
kind of first baseman to first baseman
and Dave Stewart hit me right in the
middle of the back and it was almost
like as soon as he started winding up
I've seen his eyes turn
nowhere near the place and that one's
kind of irritated me like got me right I
mean he got me good so but you know
that's just one of those things but you
so you hit mcguire then you knew did you
know going up there they're probably
gonna take it out on me
yeah pretty much yeah what a weird sport
these unwritten rules of baseball damn
crazy yeah it is it's definitely there's
some of that going on and that's you
know obviously it's change and I don't
think you know obviously the league is
you know a few years back really tried
to you know keep that stuff away you
talk about doing it the right way when
you hit a guy low and things like that
but with guys in velocity and in command
is not as good I don't think is it
wasn't it had more guys throwing harder
but a little Wilder that thing gets away
up by your head you understand you don't
want anybody get hit where it's you know
ending a career and it's dangerous those
balls run you know that Lynn had on
lefty or righty on righty that thing
that gets away usually runs right up in
right up towards the head and it's
dangerous if guys can't command it and
they're the one trying to you know say
hey I'm going to get this guy because of
whatever and he can't command it it gets
dangerous
I remember Rob Dibble had Tim Tuffle in
the middle of the bat and right in the
middle of his back and I swear to god
that baseball stayed in the middle of
his back for like a second he hit him
hit him a hundred-mile-an-hour fastball
and it's almost let it left a dent and
the ball was just staying there and I
think drop down right yes and Tuffle
wanted to go out and challenge Dibble
and he just I think he knocked the wind
out of him with that pitch I can't
imagine you get like if you hit me in
the hip okay but in this in the middle
of the back it's got to knock the breath
out of you to be honest with you it
doesn't matter really where you get hit
if you get hit solid with a baseball it
doesn't feel good so no matter where you
get it you can see how guys get
irritated because they do not feel good
that baseball can be hard Hey
no you got to run always great to catch
up with you thank you as always done all
right good that's Don Mattingly Miami
Marlins manager Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
how you drive Continental design stars
for what you do for more information
content of tire calm Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]